foreign
[Music]
I'm Chris osaki and welcome to turn 10
Studios
the team is hard at work bringing you
the next generation of Forza Motorsports
built from the ground up to take
advantage of the Xbox series consoles
this is the most technically Advanced
racing game ever made
today I'm joined by some of our amazing
team members to show you how we are
making it look real sound real and feel
real
this is Forza Motorsport
at launch Forza Motorsport features over
500 cars for you to collect race and
customize with more than 800 unique
upgrades this includes over 100 new to
Motorsport cars the most modern race
cars we've ever featured on our roster
racing is violent it's a battle on the
racetrack the advancements in our
physics model are greater than Forza
Motorsport 5 6 and 7 combined this makes
our Driving Experience more fun and
rewarding in the way the car accelerates
corners and breaks our materials and
shaders are built from the ground up at
higher resolutions and optimized for a
Cutting Edge Ray tracing experience
our paints are sourced using a
spectrophotometer to capture multiple
data points of light behavior on a
Surface this yields a paint model that
has a much more realistic light response
across color metal flake and gloss
damage and dirt buildup is unique to
each car it's now contextually aware and
more localized we simulate paint
thickness chipping and directionality
dirt accumulation is more realistic
Gathering more in the low pressure areas
like recesses and alcoves bees
Innovations tell the story of the work
you put into a race and reflects the
marks and Battle Scars of Motorsport
this is our best sounding Forza
Motorsport ever and the first to be
mixed natively for immersive audio
formats like Windows Sonic and Dolby
Atmos to create an immersive soundscape
each audio system has been rebuilt from
the ground up to deliver a new level of
Sonic depth and authenticity for our
players modifying car parts like your
exhaust and turbo change the car sounds
in Forza Motorsport just like it would
in the real world every car now has a
variety of sound possibilities based on
the parts you've installed Hardware
accelerated convolution Reverb
accurately reproduces how sounds in
Forza interact within an acoustic space
dynamically adapting to its surroundings
and creating a realistic and detailed
soundscape
[Music]
new features like our regional track
announcer system and improved Tire and
Suspension audio bring a new level of
realism to the game
here for to Motorsport like never before
every tire squeal every engine lap after
life
foreign
Motorsport launches with 20 environments
built from the ground up for this
generation you'll get to race on iconic
fan favorites as well as five all-new to
Motorsport locations including our first
in South Africa kyalami
we capture our environments to an
incredible level of detail when we
reference a track our team comes back
with over three terabytes of highly
detailed photogrammetry and Laser scan
data through the power of the Xbox
series consoles we're able to use this
data to draw up to 10 times more detail
than previous generations you'll see
Lush trees dense grass and overgrowth
vegetation animated track life
physically based lighting and volumetric
fog effects and a fully procedural cloud
system that evolves organically tracks
look alive sound alive and feel alive
with cutting-edge visuals and crowds
consisting of tens of thousands of fully
animated 3D Spectators so you're always
immersed in the pure spectacle of racing
for the first time in Forza Motorsport
fully Dynamic time of day with weather
ensures a constantly evolving Racing
Experience where no two laps ever look
the same meanwhile Dynamic track
temperatures wet driving surfaces and
rubbering in ensure that no two laps
ever play the same
I love the detail our talented team of
artists have built into kailami
[Music]
tonight and the Vista is truly
breathtaking
light glows of the city a beautiful
visual touch even the kyalami logo
itself creates visual impact every time
you see it thanks to Ray Trace Global
illumination which simulates how
hundreds of thousands of light rays
accumulate color as they bounce between
surfaces we're rendering all our
environments in 4k at 60fps with
real-time Ray tracing on track to create
true to life Reflections on all smooth
mirror and flat glass surfaces
with the incredible detail and rendering
features of our track environments Forza
Motorsport is truly a generational leap
ahead with unmatched visual Fidelity and
authenticity
Forza Motorsport is back and it's our
most comprehensive game ever with over
500 cars and 20 environments with more
new race cars than ever before
you can experience all of this in our
incredible new online racing mode and in
our all-new car building focused single
player career
we cannot wait for you to get your hands
on this incredible game
[Music]